and so uh the next year I came in and
they made me part of the social club you
know and the college DJ and it just took
off from there and it just took off from
there and the thing was we rented the
gear every weekend at10 a time you know
$15 by then and so I said to them you
know this is a bit silly that we're
paying this money why don't we buy some
gear and that way we don't have to pay
out the money and they said well how
much would it cost and I said I'd looked
in the
uh trades ahead of time and I said it'
be about £300 and we'd have our own gear
so in 30 weeks it would be paid for and
they went that makes sense uh can you
buy it for us and I said yeah so I said
I'm going to go down to London and I'll
buy it and have it shipped up here and
so I went down to um the end of our hill
we were on North Hinkley Hill and there
was a the motorway going through the
freeway for all the Americans uh the
motorway going through and I stood there
and hitchhiked down to London and I was
there for about 10 minutes and this Mini
Cooper ass pulls up this guy says where
you going I said I'm going down to
London I'm going down uh just off oxa
Street to um Tottenham Court Road to
pick up that's where all the electronic
stores were yeah to pick up some gear
and he goes oh hop in I'll drive you
I've got a store on uh Oxford Street and
so I jump in and he goes what's your
name I goes Richard and he goes oh I'm
Richard too and that's but it wasn't
Richard Blade then no no it's Richard
Shephard Richard Richard sheeper there
you go and uh so we we're driving down
to London and he said what' you do I'm a
DJ you know and he goes okay great he
goes I Got This Record Store and
everyone tries to sell their independent
uh labels and local bands through my
store cuz HMV won't and wh Smiths won't
but I will and he said and I figured I
should buy like a little recording
studio and that way the bands could not
only make the music but then they could
sell it in my store and he said but I
can't afford anything in London the
prices are crazy but up here in Oxford
uh there's a lot of places I can buy uh
that I've looked at and I found this
this is a random guy that you just gave
you a ride into London yeah picked me up
but he said I wanted to pick up a
hitchhiker cuz I was so excited to tell
him I think I found finally found a
place you know this is before cell
phones or anything and he he was excited
to tell someone that all these weeks and
months of looking for a place he'd found
goes I found this Farm that's great and
I'm going to turn it into a recording
studio and it's actually got enough
rooms that people could stay there and I
said that's great and he goes and I'm
I'm going to you know be able to put
some of the bands that want to make
music there they could stay for the
weekend and it's it's going to be
fantastic is it do did this become
something big well yeah it did kind of
you might have heard of the guy I knew
it was coming I knew it was coming so he
was great and he goes this is my record
store points to it and he goes but
Tottenham Court roads another mile and a
half down I'm going to drive you all the
way and I go oh thank you man that's so
nice of you and so we drove past uh his
record store Virgin records and we went
down to to Court Road and wait did you
just fly over the word Virgin Records
yeah yeah I did okay keep going yes so
Richard drops me off and he goes well
best of luck man and I go best of luck
with the the farm and so that was the
start for Richard Bron yeah I know wait
wait this is a random hitchhiker he
picked up was you yeah and so are you
still friends well not friends but fast
forward to uh
2005 and he was on love line and Christ
and I were driving back from the king's
head in Santa Monica I've done love line
and I went you know I should stop by and
say hello so I pulled off and went over
to Calver City where they were doing
love line from because they were doing
it I think it was on Premier Network
this when you just started first wave
yeah I was just just come back from the
Caribbean and I wasn't with krock or
anything anymore but uh I'd left on
great terms with them I was friends with
everyone great friends with Drew and uh
with Adam so I thought oh I'll pop in
and you know see if I can say hi to
Richard Branson so on the very first
break they go yeah go you know come and
say hi Richard Branson so he comes out
all long blonde hair and everything I
told him the story and he goes I don't
remember you but I remember picking up a
hitchhiker so that was you and I said
yeah and he goes I just had to tell
someone about it I was so excited come
here and he gives me a hug and he goes
so good to see you again so I looked at
him and I said so how did it work out
for
you and he laughed and he couldn't
believe it and then I said I get a
photograph with you and he goes
absolutely and he goes um my wife as
well I said she's you know obviously a
huge fan of yours and he goes come on
and he picks up Christa in his arms like
that and we got this picture of him just
standing there with a long hair and I
thought this is a guy who really
deserved the success because a nice guy